Welcome, students,
to our series
on the pharmacology
of antibiotics.
This lecture is on
fluoroquinolones.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Here are the
learning objectives,
mechanisms, mechanisms,
mechanisms,
pharmacokinetics,
mechanisms of
adverse effects,
drug interactions,
contraindications,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
Here are some links if
you wish to use them.
Here are the key
points about this
class of drugs, the
fluoroquinolones. I
won't read them to
you. It's here for
your use, however
is helpful to you.
So let us begin now. Now,
fluoroquinolones
inhibit bacterial
DNA gyroids and
topoisomerase 4.
I'll go into more
detail on that.
Fluoroquinolones
that are available
in the U.S. are
ciprofloxacin
and the respiratory
fluoroquinolones,
levofloxacin,
moxifloxacin, delafloxacin,
olfloxacin. I think
you can see what
the suffix is telling
us about these drugs.
They're all
fluoroquinolones. The
definition of a
respiratory fluoroquinolone
is one that has
activity against the
respiratory organisms
that cause pneumonia,
including streptococcus
pneumoniae.
Nalodixic acid was
the first quinolone,
so naturally it's
called first generation.
It was highly
effective against
urinary tract
infections, but it
did not achieve
systemic levels.
The fluoroquinolones
overcame that deficiency.
Ofloxacin is not
starred. Its pharmacology
is very similar
to levofloxacin.
Class properties. I
always recommend start
with the class
properties before you
ever learn a drug
name. It makes it so
much easier when you
do start to learn the
drug names. You'll
notice that it's just
one or two things
that are different.
The drugs are
taken ****** or can
be administered
IV, rapid complete
absorption from
the GI tract.
However, it's important
not to take mineral
supplements or
antacids because they
can complex with
the drugs and reduce
absorption as moderate
plasma protein binding
widely distributed with
high concentrations
in tissues and also
they will enter the
macrophages and
neutrophils, which is
important when targeting
infections that
actually replicate
within our white cells.
Renal excretion of
unchanged drugs. So
unchanged drug, we
need to be thinking
about adjusting
the dose for renal
impairment. So that's
the big picture.
So what are the
clinically relevant drug
-specific pharmacokinetic
properties.
Ciprofloxacin has
hepatic metabolism.
Importantly, it is
inhibitor of these CYPs,
1A2, 3A4.
The concentration
in urine is variable
but generally
high on the high
side, and therefore
the drug is effective
against urinary
tract infections.
Levofloxacin, it's
really the class
properties.
Minimal metabolism,
high urine
concentrations.
Moxifloxacin, we
see our phase two.
Delafloxacin, phase
two, hepatic metabolism.
Moxifloxacin
actually has fairly
low concentration
of active drug in
urine as compared
to the others.
It would be not
preferable compared to the
others for treatment of
urinary tract infections,
which do achieve
high concentrations.
Delafloxacin, certainly
half of it goes into
the urine and half
of it goes into the
feces. This is for the
oral form of the drug.
I talk about
clinically relevant
pharmacokinetics,
so let's mention
what that actually
means in my mind.
Well, a treatment is
clinically relevant,
just a treatment, if
it provides positive
benefit to how the
patient feels, how the
patient functions,
and survival for
life-threatening
diseases. It is
the perception of
benefit by the patient,
and the drug therapy
outweighs the potential
harm, which is
optimization of therapy.
We talked about that in
the early days of our
pharmacology lecture.
So, what would
be clinically
relevant pharmacokinetic
properties?
These are the
parameters that enable
prescribing the right
drug for the individual
patient at the right
dose by the right route
for the right duration
for optimal efficacy,
benefit to the patient,
and minimal harm.
looking at the
ADME parameters
the correct route
of administration
for the desired
effect and
patient adherence to
therapy now the correct
route may vary because
if the patient is
in the hospital the
patient will is ill
and will likely be
getting the IV at least
in the beginning if
the patient is at home,
well intravenous
administration is the
least favorable for
patient adherence.
Oral would probably
be the most favorable.
Does the drug
distribute to the
site of action in
the therapeutic
concentration? So the
correct dose but not
excessive concentration
which would
increase the risk
of adverse effects.
What is the hepatic
function of the patient?
We think about that for
the drug metabolizing
capacity, for the
potential for metabolism
and transport-related
drug interactions.
What is the
function of the drug
-eliminating organs,
which of course is
hepatic function
for metabolism, I
put it here again,
and the kidney.
All of this information
for dosing recommendations
can be looked
up in the literature
when you get to the
point where you need
to be able to do that.
Application of
knowledge can give the
prescriber the ability to
anticipate and mitigate
potential pharmacokinetics
-related adverse
effects and drug
interactions. It helps to
provide the right dose
for the right patient
and reduce the risk
of adverse effects.
pharmacokinetics
pharmacodynamics profile
the fluoroquinolones
have a c max to mic
or peak to mic
concentration dependent
bacterial killing all
of this is in vitro
the greater the
concentration the greater
the rate and extent
of bacterial killing
The drugs also
have a moderate
persistent bacterial
suppression
after dropping
below the MIC.
And efficacy correlates
with the total
amount of drug in
the body at steady
state, the 24-hour
AUC to MIC ratio.
The ideal dosing
regimen maximizes
the total amount of drug
administered over
a 24-hour period.
These numbers,
these values,
vary according
to the organism
that's targeted
for treatment.
Again, this
information is
given in the literature.
No need for guessing.
And as you could
imagine, these are
bactericidal at these
high concentrations.
Mechanism now. On the
left, we have a model
of the formation of
negative DNA supercoils
by DNA gyrase, the
function of DNA gyrase.
Bacteria have a circular
DNA, so we see that
at the top, and on
the left-hand side,
it's shaded more than
on the right-hand side,
and that is a light
green color shading.
This circular DNA,
this piece gets brought
over, you see that
here, and this is called
a positive super
coil, it's coiled up.
The DNA gyrase introduces
a double strand
break, which we
see right here, in
order to release the
torsional strain that
comes with this
winding up in front of
the replication fork.
This is a generic
DNA transcription
here and here's our
topoisomerase and
the winding in front.
So once the DNA is
ligated or cleaved,
the topoisomerase
then reseals it and we
see it now a negative
super coil, and that's
going to relieve the
torsional strain.
So what do quinolones
do? Quinolones bind
topoisomerase, and they
form this fluoroquinolone
-topoisomerase DNA
three-way complex.
So they bind all,
and that binding
is going to stall
that replication
fork, and it will
prevent this step.
We have the
cleavage, oh excuse
me, it'll prevent
this step.
It will have the
cleavage of the
DNA but it won't
have the resealing.
Complexes containing
broken DNA cannot
be resealed. Double
strand breaks in
DNA are generated
and that ultimately
leads to the death of
the bacterial cell.
Now topoisomerase
4 has a particular
function which is to
cause separation of
the daughter cells.
So after all of this
DNA is replicated
and there will be
two circles kind of
together like this,
then topoisomerase 4
will separate them.
So there would be
two daughter cells.
The fluoroquinolones
block that
separation step, which is
called decatenation
by the way.
You'll see that
probably on exams,
board exams, maybe
NYIT-COM exams.
So it blocks that
separation and
so they can't
separate and
therefore proliferation
is blocked.
Apparently what's
been observed in
experimentation is that
the DNA gyrase inhibition
is more prevalent
in the gram-negative
organisms, whereas
the topoisomerase for
inhibition is more
prevalent in the gram
-positive. Now,
nearly all bacteria
have both of these
topoisomerase enzymes.
It's just a matter
of what the drugs
have better affinity
for, apparently.
The different
affinities of bacterial
topoisomerases
may explain the
differences in
the spectrums of
action between these
various strokes.
Well, resistance. Not
a surprise to you,
I'm sure, that
resistance is common and
rates are growing.
There are two major
mechanisms, chromosomal
and plasmid associated.
The chromosomal are
the main mechanisms.
These include target
modification where the
point at which the drug
binds to the DNA is
altered so that the
drug is unable to bind.
to that sorry to the
topoisomerase and
reduced accumulation
of the drug so efflux
we know that bacteria
are able to express
efflux pumps against
many drugs and also
for the gram negatives
changes in the
porin structures, so
the drug can't get in.
So these, again, I'm
repeating, are the main
mechanisms. They
produce high level
resistance. The plasma
mediated mechanisms are
something called
topoprotection, topoisomerase
protection. So it
produces a protein
that protects the site
at which the drug would
bind, something called
the QNR proteins.
You can think about
this as quinolone
-resistant proteins,
quinolone-resistant
proteins, QNR, protecting
that topoisomerase
binding site, and
acetylation of the actual
drug that inactivates
it. So these are
plasmid-mediated to
repeat, and they do
produce low-level
resistance on their own.
In bacteria, mutations
can accumulate.
They can be
combined with other
mechanisms of
resistance, in which case
there will be higher
-level resistance.
Troublesome is that
resistance can emerge
during therapy among
these common infections,
E. coli and other enteric
bacteria, pseudomonas,
gonorrhea,
staphylococci,
and resistance to
one is resistance
to the rest. Next,
delafloxacin, which was
developed after
the others,
seems to be
able to still be
resistant, at
least for now.
Still remains active,
at least for now.
I put the activity
into this little
chart because
I'm hoping that
you'll be able
to spot where the
differences are
much more easily.
Levofloxacin,
moxifloxacin,
delofloxacin have
broad-spectrum
activity, including
the gram-positive.
Ciprofloxacin is
mainly gram-negative.
That's an easy way
to think about it.
Another thing is
to figure out what
are the drug
-specific features.
So moxifloxacin is
not active against
Pseudomonas, but
the others are.
Only delafloxacin has
activity against
MRSA, and
that's really about it.
Streptococcus pneumoniae,
H. influenzae,
Morsella catarrhalis,
mycoplasma
pneumoniae, chlamydia
pneumophilia,
chlamytophila
pneumoniae, sorry,
Legionella,
Neisseria meningitidis,
various respiratory
pathogens.
The Levomoxy and
Delafloxacin
are all useful.
Ciprofloxacin,
not so much.
moxifloxacin is
actually preferred of
the fluoroquinolones
not the preferred
treatment of treatment
of tuberculosis and
of course as with
all tuberculosis
treatments is given
in combination therapy
and it is an alternative
that's the way to
remember it just
kind of visualize the
chart and see what
the differences are.
Same idea for
empiric therapy
and this is not
a complete list.
Ciprofloxacin
is basically
against gram negatives.
Levofloxacin can be
used, if appropriate,
in patients for just for
all of these different
infections except,
big exception here,
when ciprofloxacin
first came
out it was like
oh great we've
got something
against gonorrhea.
Well not anymore.
Pseudomonas not
moxifloxacin
or delafloxacin.
Pseudomonas
infections mainly
because it did
not receive
a FDA indication
for that.
Well here we go with
the adverse effects. So
we see that all these
drugs seem to be really
useful assuming no
resistance. So what's
the trouble here? They're
second line. They're
not recommended at
all for uncomplicated
infections and for more
complicated infections
it's important to
consider the patient's
risk factors and weigh
the benefit versus
the risk when considering
fluoroquinolone
therapy. If it's the
right therapy, absolutely
use it and just monitor
for adverse effects.
Okay, what are they?
Potentially permanent
and disabling adverse
effects of tendons,
muscles, joints, nerves,
and the CNS. These
can all occur in the
same patient at the
same time. And there are
several U.S. boxed
warnings known as black
box warnings with the
use of fluoroquinolone
seizures, which
fortunately are rare but
can occur, increased
intracranial pressure,
headache, dizziness,
insomnia, nightmares,
depression, psychosis,
peripheral neuropathy,
which can be
irreversible. Peripheral
neuropathy, we think
about the tingling
and numbness in the
fingers and toes.
Tendon rupture.
This was originally
seen in patients who
are also taking
dexamethasone, older
patients taking
dexamethasone, together
with a fluoroquinolone.
And their Achilles
tendon would actually
rupture, either
during therapy or
following therapy.
The tendon rupture warning
extends to everyone,
and not necessarily
with dexamethasone.
But inclusion of
dexamethasone seems
to increase the
risk, apparently.
And myasthenia
gravis exacerbation
because of increased
muscle weakness.
Myasthenia gravis is
an autoimmune disease
in which the nicotinic
receptors in the
neuromuscular junction
are attacked by
the immune system.
and that can lead to
muscle weakness. And
putting a fluoroquinolone
into a patient
who has that can
really lead to serious
muscle weakness. So
what do we think about
with muscle weakness?
It's serious
respiratory depression.
Well, that's not all.
Nausea, vomiting,
diarrhea, well,
that's pretty typical
of all of them.
QT interval prolongation.
Glucose dysregulation.
Diabetic patients
can either
suffer hyperglycemia
or serious,
possibly deadly
hypoglycemia.
Aneurysm or aortic
dissection. C.
difficile infection
is associated to a
higher degree with
fluoroquinolones
than some of the
other antibiotics.
phototoxicity and
hypersensitivity
reactions as
with everything.
Pregnancy, can we
give these in pregnant
patients? Well
they do cross the
placenta, they can be
found in cord blood.
There was animal evidence
in the beginning of some
malformations in
the joints of the
infant rodents that
it was tested on but
in people over all
these years since
the drugs have been
available there have
been no specific
teratogenic effect
or increased
pregnancy risk
identified but
we still have to
remember all
those other risks
but if it's the
right drug for the
patient such as a
person with tuberculosis
or inhalational
anthrax or plague
then by all means
it should be used
but we have other
drugs for those too
adverse effects are
might be increased in
the older patient
pediatrics well there
are dosing recommendations
available for
infants and older
children, adolescents.
They're not first
-line agents,
especially in pediatric
patients, because
of all of these
potential adverse
effects. But if
it's the right drug,
then that's what
should be given.
Arthralgias and joint
pain during therapy
are more common in
children receiving
fluoroquinolones
relative to comparator
drugs in the studies
that were done.
Importantly, long-term
joint abnormalities
and growth inhibition
have not been noted.
Drug interactions.
I mentioned a few
slides ago, CYP1A2
and 3A4 inhibitor.
Theophylline is a 1A2
substrate. Theophylline
has a narrow
therapeutic window. This
interaction is frequently
seen on practice
questions for the
boards. It is important
because of theophylline's
narrow therapeutic
window. However,
theophylline is not
used that much, but
it is still used, and
CYP3A4 substrates
also can be affected.
All right, QT
interval prolongation,
numerous drugs can
cause this, including
the macrolides that
we talked about.
Glucocorticoids I mentioned
with the increased
risk of tendon
rupture, and antacids
and other divalent
cations because of
decreased absorption of
the fluoroquinolone. So
that's just a separate
by two hours to
make sure the drug gets
out of the stomach,
out of the gut, and
absorbed before the
antacid is given or
the mineral supplement.
So some questions. How
is gaining knowledge
about class and drug
-specific pharmacokinetic
properties relevant
to optimizing
drug therapy for the
individual patient?
What parameters
are associated
with clinical
efficacy and,
importantly, provide
dosing guidance?
What are the bacterial
targets of the
fluoroquinolones?
I know, I can hear
you in my mind's
ear saying what they
are. What are the
chromosomal and
plasmid-mediated
resistance mechanisms?
Which mechanisms confer
low-level resistance?
What risks must
be weighed against
the benefit
when considering
therapy with a
fluoroquinolone?
And here are the answers.
Right drug, right
patient, right
dose, right
route, right time.
Right duration of
time. because it
provides the practitioner,
the prescriber,
with the ability to
anticipate and mitigate
potential
pharmacokinetics-related
adverse effects and
drug interactions.
So what parameters?
CMAX to MIC or
peak to MIC ratio
and the AUC24
to MIC ratio.
And also the drug
has a moderate
post-antibiotic
effect. targets,
DNA gyrase and
topoisomerase 4.
Chromosomal mutations
in genes for
the fluoroquinolone
binding regions,
these would be
point mutations.
Genes for efflux
pumps, genes for
altered porins or
reduced porins.
Plasma transfer genes
for the protection
protein known as
QNR, or quinolone
resistance protection
protein, and also
drug inactivation by
anacetyltransferase.
It's the plasma transfer
of genes, those two
mechanisms, that
confer the low-level
resistance unless they are
coupled with chromosomal
resistance mutations
or they accumulate.
And significant
toxicities include
peripheral
neuropathy, tendon
rupture, QT prolongation,
CNS effects.
Patient factors at
increased risk of
experiencing adverse
effects are older
patients, pediatric
patients, pregnant
patients, patients
with myasthenia gravis,
diabetic patients. And
this is how you can
figure out what would
be the cautions and
contraindications. How
do the adverse
effects, how do
the patient's
organ functions
relate to the
adverse effects?
And now in summary,
pharmacokinetics,
good oral
bioavailability, antacids,
multivalent cations
will complex with them.
********* high concentrations
in body tissues,
most body tissues,
high concentrations
in urine, except
moxifloxacin, not so much.
Efficacy is
associated with a peak
-to-mic ratio, 24-hour
AUC to MIC ratio,
and the post
-antibiotic effects.
The drugs, the
fluoroquinolones, inhibit
DNA gyrase and topoisomerase
4. This introduces
strand breaks and cell
death. In addition
of topo4 prevents
decatenation. They are
bactericidal at those
high concentrations.
They're concentration
dependent killing.
Chromosomally mediated
resistance point
mutations in the
topoisomerases is
where the fluoroquinolones
bind. Reduced
intracellular
accumulation. And then
plasmid mediated,
which is the
topoprotection protein,
QNR, and acetylase.
Ciprofloxacin is
active against the gram
-negative aerobic
bacteria, including
pseudomonas. Moderate
activity against
gram Positives, it's
hardly used for that
because so many other
drugs are better.
Levofloxacin, Moxie,
Della, O-floxacin,
they're all respiratory
fluoroquinolones
because they are
active against the
atypicals and
streptococcus pneumoniae.
Levofloxacin has good
gram-negative bacteria
spectrum also,
including pseudomonas.
I didn't say it before,
it isn't necessary
for you to memorize
it, but levofloxacin is
good, given once a day
for most infections.
Moxifloxacin,
improved gram
-positive activity,
reduced activity
against gram
-negative bacteria,
and I didn't
specifically mention it
before, but it's on
the chart. it has
anaerobic activity
it is the only one
with anaerobic bacteria
i mean activity
and
it is effective
against anaerobic lung
infections it does not
have activity against
bacteroides but it is
useful for lung infections
like abscess and
anaerobic infections
delafloxacin is a
respiratory fluoroquinolone
that's also got activity
against MRSA. It's
the only one in the
fluoroquinolones group.
It has been approved
by the FDA for
acute bacterial skin
and skin structure
infections and caused
by aerobic gram
positives, MRSA,
and it's also useful
for community
acquired pneumonia and
that's indicated on
the chart earlier.
Toxicities, a number
of safety alerts,
a number of cautions,
CNS effects,
peripheral neuropathy,
tendonitis, tendon
rupture, worsening
of myasthenia gravis,
muscle weakness,
QT, interval
prolongation,
hypersensitivity
reactions.
Use in Pregnancy,
only if the benefit
outweighs the
risk, and these are
some serious
infections listed here.
Multidrug-resistant
tuberculosis,
inhalational anthrax,
plague.
Pediatrics,
again, if
benefit outweighs
risk. Older patient,
again, if benefit
outweighs risk, and
the risk of adverse
effects tends
to be increased in
the older patient.
Drug interactions,
we have
ciprofloxacin, CYPs, 1A2.
Please do remember that
theophylline toxicity
risk. It keeps coming
up over and over.
And 3A4.
And it just so happens
there are organic
anion transport
-related interactions
also listed in the
drug monograph.
All fluoroquinolones
prolong the QT
interval. They
should not be given
with glucocorticoids
because they can
increase the risk
of tendon rupture.
And diantrivalent
cations will reduce
the absorption
from the GI tract.
And here are the
answers. I hope
you looked at
the questions and
tried to answer
them yourself first.
And that concludes the
lecture on
fluoroquinolones.